in order to understand the world one has
to turn away from it on occasion We are
the world and the world is us it is an
addictive form of symbiosis one would
say toxic at times the world is our
truth but truth is a dangerous word man
is always prey to his truths once he has
admitted them he cannot free himself
from them once truth is the Bedrock of
one's identity without our truths
without our belief systems our identity
becomes shaking if someone challenges
our truths we take it personally and we
become insulted it is hard to escape
this almost impossible almost absurd and
the man who has become conscious of the
Absurd is forever bound to it the Absurd
is elusive but inescapable forever there
to remind us of the bizarre predicament
we call reality a predicament that we
need to reconcile with man stands face
to face with a rational he feels is
within him his longing for happiness and
for reason the Absurd is born of this
confrontation between the human need and
the unreasonable Silence of the world
the Absurd is such a fertile place for
us to become disoriented and connected
to the misery of things
from the moment absurdity is recognized
it becomes a passion the most harrowing
of all but whether or not one can live
with one's passions whether or not one
can accept their law which is to burn
their heart they simultaneously exalt
that is the whole question the heart
Knows No Limits the heart feels and
guides it transforms and reforms the
heart to some extent gives birth to the
Absurd the Absurd does not liberate it
binds it does not authorize all actions
everything is permitted does not mean
that nothing is forbidden as Jung once
wrote life itself has no rules that is
its mystery in its unknown law what you
call knowledge is an attempt to impose
something comprehensible on life
for the Absurd our humanity is bound to
oscillate between moments of clarity and
moments of vagueness the Absurd is born
of this confrontation between the human
need and the unreasonable Silence of the
world this must not be forgotten this
must be Clank 2 because the whole
consequence of a life can depend on it
the irrational the human Nostalgia and
the Absurd that is born of their
encounter these are the three characters
in the drama that must necessarily end
with all the logic of which an existence
is capable
just like that time goes by we are
condemned to choose between surrender
and resistance and both seem so
unilaterals every day of a nanny last
year's lifetime carries us but
items comes when we have to carry it we
live on the future we live with
tomorrows later on with when you have
made your way you will understand when
you are old enough
that he relevances are wonderful but
they keep us trapped inside a loop yet a
day comes when a man notices that he is
not young anymore does he faces time but
simultaneously he situates himself in
relation to time he takes his place in
it he admits that he has to travel to
its end he belongs to time and by the
horror that seizes him he recognizes his
worst enemy tomorrow he has longing for
tomorrow whereas everything in him
ought to rejected that Revolt of the
flesh is the Absurd this kind of
reasoning can lead to Madness that's
what happened to Sisyphus he went mad he
went mad and tried to trick reality and
the gods and the gods made him pay the
gods condemn Sisyphus to ceaselessly
roll a rock to the top of a mountain and
the stone would fall back of its own
weight they had thought with some reason
that there is no more Dreadful
punishment than futile and hopeless
labor Sisyphus is the Absurd hero Keys
as much through his passions as through
his torture that's why his story hits
home if this myth is tragic and that is
because our hero is conscious where
would his torture be if his punishment
wasn't Eternal the worker of the day
works every day in his life at the same
tasks and his fate is no less absurd but
it is tragic only at the rare moments
when it becomes conscious we keep
rolling The Rock to the top of a
mountain while knowing that once we
reach the top we will have to do this
again and again and again yet we keep
doing it without really being able to
justify why I leave Sisyphus at the top
of a mountain one always finds one's
burden again and suzyfuss has embraced
his burden The Rock has become his own
and the sky above the rock is his own
world this universe henceforth without a
master seems to him neither sterile nor
futile each atom of that stone its
mineral flake of that night filled
Mountain in itself forms a world
the struggle itself towards the heights
is enough to feel a man's heart one must
imagine since he was happy
hi guys this video is sponsored by
brilliant as you know I really do
sponsored videos but brilliant is such
an interesting platform and I couldn't
refuse when they approached me while
navigating through the Absurd I feel
that learning new things is Central to
the alleviation of absurdity especially
things that I find quite challenging but
fundamental to my understanding of
reality I have tried many methods of
learning over the years but I'm almost
certain that the best way to learn
anything is by doing it yourself
especially by learning interactively
Interactive Learning helps you learn way
more effectively than just watching
lecture videos Brilliance platform is
designed around this idea take for
instance this incredible course on
astrophysics in this course you can
learn intuitively Concepts like matter
radiation exoplanets black holes and
dark matter the structure is great and
you can progress from one topic to the
next gradually and seamlessly I got
hooked and I was playing around with the
course for hours I'm sure that brilliant
is ideal for students who want to deeply
understand the STEM related topics but
it is also perfect for every curious
human who wants to delve into
interesting Concepts like astrophysics
Quantum objects logic and physics of the
everyday to try everything brilliant has
to offer free for a full 30 days visit
brilliant.org slash metamorphosis 77 the
first 200 of you will get 20 of
Brilliance annual premium subscription
enjoy again thanks for watching see you
soon
[Music]
thank you